the chancellor on the hs2 site in
solihull today a government hoping
Railway infrastructure will help level
up this country but with an enormous
hole in the public finances fast and
need to build back economic credibility
economic competence is Central to the
Tory party brand and what voters
associate your party with isn't the
truth that what has happened recently
has damaged that reputation I do accept
that you know we've had a rocky period
in the last couple of months I wish that
we hadn't had what happened with the
mini budget and all the turbulence that
happened there it was if you like the
most catastrophic moment I think in
recent political history and certainly
for the conservative party economically
do you accept that the party is
responsible well I accept that there was
turbulence and as I say I regret it
but we reversed those decisions I did it
within three days of becoming Chancellor
I think we have demonstrated that we
think what happened was wrong yeah we've
corrected it and we put the country back
on the right track trying to get back on
track but with economic pain to come
this a chancellor who reversed one
controversial agenda but replaced it
with the largest tax burden since the
second world war you can see why Jacob
rees-mogged described your Autumn
statement as a decision to lose you the
next election is that fair well I think
what people want from a conservative
government
is uh is a team of people who will take
the difficult decisions irrespective of
whether it's good for their political
fortunes because it's right for the
country this time will damage in
economic credibility in the short term
in the longer run brexit hurting growth
the office for Budget responsibility
predicting a four percent hit to the
economy that four percent GDP reduction
over the longer term amounts to about a
hundred billion pounds in Lost trade and
approximately 40 billion pounds in tax
revenue do you accept those figures or
you just do not accept them Beth I don't
accept the four percent that four
percent is a figure that says the OVR
figures sometimes you have to write them
such as inflation you're happy to take
that one yes I don't don't have to
accept all of them and that's one that I
don't set the ones you like well I
accept the ones I agree with and I don't
accept the ones I don't agree with that
one I don't agree with because that is
saying absent other changes uh that
could be the impact and I think we
announced some very big changes this a
chancellor clear-eyed
stormy times ahead and we will continue
to feel the pain for some time yet Beth
Rigby Sky News solihull in Birmingham